[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis aujourd'hui nous
allons tous jouer ensemble avec mirabel
petit louis et gros ours et vous allez
jouer avec nouveau au moins je suis bien
content je vais jouer avec les petits
enfants à cache cache
je descends patron europe
[Rires]
c'est un jeu très facile écoutez bien
petit louis et mirabel vont se cacher
dans leur maison pendant qu'ils se
cachent
vous mettrez vos mains devant les yeux
pour ne pas voir où il se cache et quand
ils diront ça y est vous aiderez gros
ours à les trouver et les chercherait
avec lui ou se sont-ils cacher ses deux
petits brigands
voyons voyons
l'homme de dieu voyons voir sous la
table non à à la non dans la cheminée
coucou
le met où sont ils ah bon voyons voir
dans la chambre et non la fin mais non
émis sans fin dit louie coucou à abou
diaby ville derrière les eaux aucun ce
speed mais je n'y avais pas pensé
tikok je vous la prochaine fois tu me
trouves la paille car chez vous vite on
va voir ça on le trouvera bien des spas
à à moi je vais les trouver tout de
suite
mais où sont ils à eux je lui dit et ils
sont sûrement dans l'armoire
ah non elle n'y sont pas mais où sont
ils ont leur lot aux urnes donnent chaud
euros alors les enfants
vous savez où sont cachés mirabel et
petit louis vous avez trouvé
oui c'est très bien mais gros ours lui
n'a pas encore trouvé
nous allons l'aider un petit peu oh oui
merci patron mais qu'il a fait venir à
bâle et p'tit louis est de l'autre côté
et au style and raise est tombé ce que
je suis fort quand même
la dernière fois et j'irai dormir car je
suis fatigué
[Musique]
voyons poids euros et sont pas là mais
mais où sont-ils à mai à une ruine ne
sont pas sous le lit au fond les coquins
il était dedans on le lit c'est une très
bonne idée car il est tard et pat
symonds qui sait qu'ils jouent très bien
cache cache
ah bon bonne nuit les enfants dormaient
vite là j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
ni mirabel elle est quand même un peu
bêta nounours oui
alors les enfants vous avez bien joué à
cache-cache
moi je me suis bien amusé petit louis et
mirabel se sont très bien caché et ce
pauvre gros ours a eu beaucoup de mal
pour les trouver
oui patron c'est vrai je ne suis pas
très doué pour ce je suis un peu bête
alors en route
venus est enfin faite de doux rêves
à demain 1 demain les enfants
[Musique]
oh